[Music]
Russian Orthodox Christianity runs deep
within the night wolves motorcycle club
they even have their own bike riding
monk a chaplain called father Gary how
can I resist I have to meet him another
step to understanding this new Russian
vision I meet him here at love row
outside of Moscow lover is a holy
russian orthodox christian enclave of
cathedrals and monasteries akin to a
mini Vatican
so do you ride father yes really
what bike do you ride no Kakuma this
again thank you for your mother we star
when we first ride and surgeon saw him
and said that's what we need that is
good report also tptp Remini new new
headmaster the night walls
they they were trying to find something
and they found it
[Music]
if I'm trying to understand the Russian
identity then one must also understand
you know Russian Orthodox Christianity
the Superstock ecclesia dobrynia
Christian stone
[Music]
because the Russell casse the hippo cars
mr. sleepy on a girls and often violent
what a year and fundamentally uses nine
energy every poor have a historical
period it was based on that she can see
the church the role of the eyes this has
been incredible
this has really helped my understanding
[Music]